[Musik]
das ist ja genug guy ritchies film
theater ist ungefähr die zwanzigste kino
oder fernsehverfilmung der atus legende
soll gleichzeitig der anfang sein einer
krimiserie mit geschichten aus sieben
agenten kreis daraus ergeben sich für
den film 2
zum einen versuchen die set designer und
kostümdesigner konnte aber alles
bisherige dadurch zu überbieten das ist
noch größer machen also eine riesige
burg camelot eine ebenso riesige kulisse
des frühmittelalterlichen londons und
natürlich gewaltige landschaften
andererseits erfüllt sich möglichst
viele erzählerische optionen dadurch
offenzuhalten erinnern ganz kleinen teil
der tus sage erzählt ist die jugend des
knaben aber wer knapp dem tödlichen
attentat auf seinen vater infocenter
kontrollen ist bis er dann gerufen wird
um in camelot das schwert excalibur aus
den feldern zu ziehen
[Musik]
da es ihm als einzige gelingt muss er
der zukünftige wahre könig seine dreht
sich dann ab einen regulären feldzug in
den bösen könig fortgang der von jude
law mit einiger woche klarheit aber auch
großer virtuosität verkörpert wird ich
dachte du bist mein bauch und jetzt
stellt sich heraus dass du eine viel
bedeutendere schachfigur ist und es wäre
töricht von mir es nicht meine mutter
ganz anders meiner meinung nach charlie
hunnam in der hauptrolle des helden aber
der ziemlich blass wirkt und weshalb für
mich eher ein reinfall ist sie lieben
die festung ein
und wie gehen sich die ford anders über
eine partnerin die französin astrid
berges frisbey jedoch einigen den zauber
hat was er bei diesem film leider nicht
richtig zur geltung kommen kann
es ist einfach so dass der film von
lauter sorge um seine effekte und
individuelle übersteigerung dessen was
sie schon kennen
das eigentliche die geschichte das was
zwischen menschen auf der leinwand
passiert vernachlässigt und dadurch mehr
wie die vorstufe übergangsform zu einem
videospiel aussieht als wäre ein echter
spielfilm nach einer sagenhaften
vorlagen und was passiert jetzt
du weißt was jetzt passiert du bist
schnell zulegen